votre homme à main gauche avec le doigt
sur la détente et 30 cm trop près ce qui
veut dire que votre main droite est déjà
mort mais il ne le sait pas encore je
suis navré pour sa famille
9 secondes
c'est le temps que je vous accorde pour
des idées de votre sort neuf secondes
je commence vraiment à apprécier cet
endroit
et ses habitants
et maintenant j'ai l'intime conviction
que je suis précisément là où je dois
être alors quoi que vous fassiez vos
camarades et vous je vous en prie allez
le faire ailleurs vous menacez je vous
mets en garde
c'est une team ex
non c'est
votre mère médian que je comprime sur
une échelle de 1 à 10
je suis à trois à quatre vous tirer
dessus c'est parce que vous voulez c'est
pas ce que je veux et c'est pas ce
qu'ils veulent
dites à vos camarades de s'en aller
vous faisiez quoi dans cette ferme en
Sicile je vous ai dit au téléphone que
je passais par là
ne me prenez pas pour une idiote je suis
en train de monter
la police a découvert plusieurs corps
dans ce vignoble
vous les avez tués vous croyez que j'ai
une tête à tuer des gens je commence à
envisager cette possibilité
rester dans le coin
j'en suis qu'au début
[Musique]
moi aussi
ma colle
[Musique]